it doesn't get much better than reruns
of the office and sometimes you notice
things you never caught before from
creepy clown paintings a Call of Duty
screen names here are some of the best
Easter eggs to look out for the next
time you settle in to watch America's
favorite workplace in action even the
most casual viewers of the office know
that the American series didn't begin
with an original idea it's a remake
inspired by a British show by the same
name this original series run from 2001
to 2003 and focus on the fictional Paper
Company Wernham Hogg in the British town
of Slough the American show takes place
in Scranton Pennsylvania but it's still
us a connection to its British cousins
hometown in the season 5 episode blood
drive Michael pulls together a
depressing little Valentine's Day
shindig for all of his single coworkers
harboring secret hopes that he will be
able to reconnect with a woman he met
earlier in the day as he shows off the
flyer he's created for the event the
camera zooms in revealing that the
address for Dunder Mifflin is 175 slough
Avenue the address seems to be a nod to
the location of the original Wernham
Hogg Paper Company it's not a one-time
incident either in the last episode of
season six
Dwight refers to the street by name
again cancel it I want you to make an
offer at 1725 Slough Avenue make him an
offer they can't refuse the story of
Angela and Dwight's secret love is a
long one
starting early on in the show and
winding through several ups and downs
before they finally tie the knot Schrute
style while standing in their own graves
in the series finale truly there the
show's perfect match to the point where
they even seem to have the same favorite
song it's made clear from early on that
Angela is a huge fan of the little
drummer boy every time a karaoke machine
is fired up that's the song she looks
for she even has Sandy if they can use
it for their first dance when they're
planning their wedding is there any way
our first dance can be to my favorite
song the little drummer boy with that in
mind it's interesting not in the pilot
for the show it's none other than the
assistant to the regional manager
himself was shown aggressively humming
the particular Carol as he sets up for
work
no gifts for you does this imply that
the relationship between the two goes
back even further than the beginning of
the show either way the connection seems
too clear to be an accident the whole
teapot episode in season two is an
iconic moment in the Pam and Jim
timeline after Michael turns a simple
Secret Santa Christmas party into an
impromptu white elephant gift swap Jim
is frustrated to find that his
romantically in tension teapot gift for
Pam has fallen into the hands of his
nemesis Dwight I get sinus infections
and sinus infections can be cured by
making your tea from green tea lucious
Pam strong and pouring it directly into
notes like so Pam ultimately makes the
right move though by choosing to
exchange a fancy new iPod for Jim's
thoughtful if humble gift instead but
that isn't the only time that the gift
appears in the show almost two years
later in the season 4 episode French
wars Pam meets with the exquisitely
refined finer things Club that's a club
enjoys a fancy lunch the very same tea
pot Pam got from a soon-to-be beau shows
up on the table he is hoping you have
been washed thoroughly hopefully several
times since Dwight shoved it up his nose
well the show focuses pretty tightly on
a small handful of characters the rest
have Dunder Mifflin's employees usually
F their own lives going on in the
background complete with their own
long-running plots
take for instance Stanley's troubled
marriage which only gets worse as a
series goes on the issue even comes to a
head in the season six opener gossip in
which Michael leaks a secret of Stanley
having an affair to the entire office
while that episode ends with Stanley
getting a small measure of cathartic
revenge it turns out that the struggling
salesman actually does want to improve
his relationships sort of in the season
7 episode ultimatum Pam encourages our
co-workers to come up with New Year's
resolutions some of these are minor
items like a Pam attempting to drink
less caffeine but others get pretty
ridiculous like Creed trying to do the
perfect cartwheel or Dwight's search for
well let's just call it romance my
resolution is need a loose woman the
resolution that has to take the cake
though is Stanley's double commitment to
quote be a better husband and boyfriend
each of those on their own is an
admirable goal but it might be pretty
difficult to pull off both at the same
time as the last two seasons of the
office unfold
Dwight slowly but surely sees his life
fall into place in virtually every way
he finds
and wittingly has a son guess his black
belt inherits the 1600 a kirby farm and
finally along last becomes a regional
manager of the Scranton branch of Dunder
Mifflin it's not just the big stuff
though
Dwight's life is so perfect at this
point that even his smallest most
obscure wishes start to come true case
in points the rocking chair went white
accompanies Michael to a cocktail party
at David Wallace's house way back in
season three he spends time admiring a
wooden rocking chair in Wallace's son's
bedroom and declares that he wants one
for himself oh good you're up
hey who makes this chair cut the season
nine more than half a decade later in
the episode the farm twice is
interviewed as he sits in a gorgeous
wooden rocking chair which just so
happens to look exactly like the one he
was wishing for six seasons earlier
Michael Scott's is proud of his
possessions and nowhere is this made
more clear than in the season 4 episode
dinner party in which Michael exhibits
his pathetically small plasma screen
television I will just stand here and
watch television for hours I love it I
love this TV later in the episode Jan
throws one of Michael's many dundie
awards utter crapping the screen and
infuriating Michael in the process that
isn't the last time we see Michael's
beloved and broken miniature TV though
the wall-mounted wonder made a cameo a
year later tucked behind another TV and
the fifth season episode Dream Team if
that wasn't enough it shows up yet again
nearly two whole seasons later in the
episode garage sale sitting plain as day
on Michael and Holly's table it looks
like the more grounded influence of
Holly may have finally convinced Michael
to let go of his prized entertainment
possession once and for all that's an
interesting little side note to the
garage sale also shows the creepy clown
painting first seen when Jim buys palmer
house in season 5 hopefully whoever
bought it was able to keep it out of the
hands of the notorious Scranton art
thieves I tried to move it but he is
really known in they're worried about
art theft I guess art thieves in this
neighborhood in the season 2 episode the
injury Michael Scott wakes up and steps
on his George Foreman grill cooking his
foot in the process while the injury is
minor he ends up milking it all day long
when asked why he had a George Foreman
grill by his bedside in the first place
he explains that every night before he
goes to sleep he lays out six pieces of
bacon on a grill in his bedroom when he
wakes up he pops on the grill goes
to sleep and then wakes up a second time
for the delicious smell of sizzling
bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's
perfect way to start today
it appears that Michaels morning bacon
habits die hard the grill shows up yet
again two seasons later in the season 4
episode dinner party as Michael and Jan
give Jim and Pam a rather uncomfortable
tour of their bedroom for all of her
quirky erratic behavior
Jan's apparently okay with the smell of
bacon each morning after it's been
sitting out all night a good portion of
season 3 follows Jim as he tries to get
away from his crush on Pam and attempts
to begin a new life at a Dunder Mifflin
branch in Stamford one episode the
Cooper follows a Stanford squad as they
practice team-building exercises by
playing call of duty against each other
the group is highly skilled at playing
the video game at this point
but the Scranton newcomer spectacularly
fails get on the bandwagon saboteur
saboteur I'm gonna kill you for real in
order to give a new coworker a hand
Caryn shows Jim as a navigate out of a
corner only to shoot him a moment later
that's when we get to see her screen
name for these interoffice deathmatches
Karen the Jim's lair pretty specific but
also pretty appropriate Michael Scott
has been known to bend the truth from
time to time and that's to be expected
from a guy who was Dunder Mifflin's top
salesman for two years running back in
the day when it comes to his management
skills though the man seems a bit more
insecure and determined to prove a point
there's a famous world's best boss mug
that he bought himself one of the first
things we see in the show's pilots
that's not Michaels only dubious claim
to fame a plaque holding a certification
can frequently be seen on the wall of
his office sharp-eyed viewers may know
that it's not a diploma it's a
certificate of authority Forrest watch
even better judging by the slightly
misspelled brand name it identifies
Michael as a proud owner of a knockoff
while the writing on the certificate can
be difficult to make out as one episode
where it's clearly visible and it makes
for an often-overlooked second layer to
a gag you can see it in a season 4
finale goodbye toby which also happens
to be the same episode in which michael
is forced to give us watch to toby as a
goodbye present after being an awful
boss for so many years i am going to
give toby your watch
if that's not poetic justice we don't
know what is that's a good portion of
the series devoted to the ongoing duel
between assistant regional managers in
one corner of the range we have the
obvious candidate Dwight Schrute that's
where you have an assistant regional
manager yes it is assistant to the
regional manager same thing no it's not
it's lower sounds close his endless
pursuit to escape being the assistant to
the regional manager doesn't quite send
them to the Leapfrog the entire issue by
being made the full play manager in
season 9 at which time he appoints
himself as his own assistant to the
assistant to the regional manager in the
other corner we have jim halpert's while
he does spend some time as co-manager in
season 6 Jim actually climbs a corporate
ladder to the assistant Regional Manager
position much faster than that in the
season 3 episode the wali Jim Karen and
Andy after work late and end up drinking
a bit too much while errata at one point
the camera shows Jim passed out on his
desk with his name place card in front
of him it reads jim halpert's assistant
regional manager got a single to the
insights seems we have a winner most of
the time Creed is the one in the office
it wasn't quite what he seems I run a
small fake ID company from my car with a
laminating machine and I swiped from the
shara station however in one episode
it's none other than Jim Halpert who
seems to have a secret identity as all
truly devoted fans will recall season
four kicks off with Meredith Palmer
being struck by Michael Scott's car it's
a banner incident on the show that kicks
off a running joke and even makes it
into the montage of incidents reference
in the seasons of love parody but the
crew sings to Michael that is very less
than the ceremony right before he exits
the show in season 7 but Meredith
returns to work after the accident in
the season 4 episode launch party
she asked Jim to sign her cast he agrees
before realizing that Meredith's injured
pelvis has presented him with a pretty
unusual place to sign a cast needless to
say it's a little uncomfortable even
without Meredith's awkward flirting so
uncomfortable in fact that it might just
a broken Jim's character as he awkwardly
signs his name a fans might notice that
looks an awful lot like it says John
kasinski rather than Jim Halpert
he even dots to eyes when he's finished
his character's name only has one the
Schrute family is well known for its
sense of tradition longevity and
attention to detail while this can be
seen in everything from the venerable
Schrute farms family home - Dwight's
impeccable work perform
as one thing that sums it all up
perfectly the American flag
not just any American flag though we're
talking about the one flying from the
porch of Schrute farms when some of the
group visits to wait on his family farm
in the episode doomsday in season eight
they pass a flag on the way out if you
look closely it's missing some stars 35
to be precise a 15 star flag was used
between 1795 and 1818 which also happens
to be the period during which fruit
farms was founded the accuracy isn't
just fun to spots it's also
appropriately located on the home of the
most likely person in the entire office
who would care about the detail like
that in the first place the season 5
episode the surplus follows the office
as they struggle to decide how to spend
the budgetary surplus before it reverts
back to corporates the decisions puts a
group into two factions one in favor of
getting new chairs the other for getting
a new copier critically Pam and Jim find
themselves on opposite sides of the
discussion making this one of the few
times of the newly engaged couple are
pitted against one another at one point
Oscar and Jim take Michael out to lunch
in order to schmooze him about the
benefits of getting a new copier when
they return Jim brings Pam some tiramisu
from the restaurants Pam jokingly takes
a gift with a smile only to then throw
it into the garbage can in defiance
clearly Pam will not be bought off with
fancy cake the back-and-forth is comical
but it turns out that the delicious
dessert hasn't at the end of the line
quite yet
a bit later in the episode Michael had
seen eating tara misu as he talks to
David Wallace on the phone then to bring
it all home during a big speech designed
to cover the fact that he's shooting for
a bonus for returning the surplus to
corporates Michael reveals where he got
his snack from as he berates the office
for being spoiled we are spoiled because
we throw out perfectly good tiramisu
because there's a little tiny hair on it
the most surprising thing that's not
even the weirdest food choice Michael
makes in this one episode every showers
is list of slip-ups and continuity
mistakes the office for instance will
occasionally show an exterior shot with
a suspiciously Californian palm tree and
what's supposed to be a chilly morning
in Scranton Pennsylvania something
that's especially noticeable in season
three's Traveling Salesman there are a
few others that slipped through the
cracks low and you can spot one in
season eights pool party in the episode
the staff heads over to Robert
California's house after hours in order
to throw one last party before he sells
a home off to the highest bidder well
most of the crew spends time taken
advantage of their busses luxurious
indoor pool another group has taken on a
long
see tour of the mansion led by mr.
California himself as they go along
observing each room and sucking up to
California as the élysée monologues each
member of the tourist gifted with their
own bottle of wine recklessly taken from
the soon to be sold wine cellar at one
point as they observe a king-sized bear
rug made from two bears sewn together
oscar takes a swig from his bottle only
to reveal a note on the button that
reads Oscar that wasn't there earlier
either the accountant is extremely
particular about labeling his things or
somebody forgot to remove the prop label
before the cameras started rolling the
office is known for having some of the
best cold opens in sitcom history
Michael and White's attempt at making a
parkour video Michaels truly incredible
while the gift worthy reaction to Toby's
return
Randall parks appearance as Asian Jim
for one of the most elaborate entries in
given Dwight's ongoing prank war they're
all classics but one of the best card
opens for the show takes place in the
season 3 episode product recall in it
Jim arrives to work a decked out in an
outfit that makes him look just like
Dwight's from the dorky haircut to the
glasses short sleeve shirt and beeper
the entire ensemble is on point bears
beats battlestar galactica after his
initial arrival jim explains that he got
the outfit on the cheap spending just
for books on the glasses and pulling the
rest of the pieces together for a mere
seven extra dollars according to the
total that he adds up on his toy test
calculator watch the grand total for the
prank was a very affordable sum of $11
it's a memorable joke and one of the
highlights of the series but what really
puts it over the top is a subtle moment
that were treated to at the end of the
episode angela frustrated by a day of
filling in on customer service calls
rips into kevin for failing to add up
the numbers on a payroll form correctly
the numbers in question the same ones I
had up on the calculator watch back in
the cold open for plus 7 that's a little
too specific to be a coincidence so
we're left with one amazing fact not
only did Jim pull off an a-plus prank
but he also managed to get reimbursed
for it as a business expense
hey if Michael can spends company money
hand-over-fist for those big dinners at
a local Chili's then Jim should be able
to expense costs incurred while boosting
office morale the only question left is
whether Dwight thought to file those
same forms while he dressed up as Jim
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel ant at
the Bell to you
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you